let's bring chris in chris i am here
i have always been here i do not leave
how far were you
in the process of finishing your special
before the whole shutdown happened
i was so close man i was like five jokes
away
from a full hour uh and then they were
like hey
if you sneeze you die i get in the house
and i was like all right
damn okay cool yeah and a lot of the
jokes don't carry over like i had a joke
that was like black people don't get
coronavirus
uh which didn't age well at all
i mean my my whole set was about how you
know covet is a hoax and it's gonna go
away in april oh so then that means that
trump just stole your material
so it's it's it's honestly comedy's
comedy's just gone to another level yeah
you and i were talking last night
about even if we got the green light
tomorrow we still need to tour before
to essentially work out uh the specials
yeah maybe an outdoor
show have you done anything that's like
outdoor or virtual shows
yeah outside shows are cool but i didn't
i didn't feel
good it without a top hat turned upside
down to collect money afterwards
no it feels like it just feels like
you're just yelling outside
uh yeah i i've looked at the outdoor
shows where it's just like a guy yelling
in a field i can't do outdoor shows
because the way i look
if i yell at people in a field people
think i'm just announcing the rules to
an ultimate frisbee game
that's about to start all right no
attack backs we got double ups no
touches
this guy loves it i can't perform in the
field because you perform for free and
working free in the field would not make
my ancestors proud it'd set me back a
lot
no not the time for that no not to move
forward
this is cool so a lot of people got sent
uh most of you should have got
sent a little gift box from hbo max
yes i did snacks i think oh this is cool
i you know hbo max sent me one too sort
of a no hard feelings for all the hbo
max jokes
very nice of them i love it man yo i'm
honestly very excited about this they
sent me a lot of cool stuff to send me
two tickets
two tickets to nowhere this is my first
time getting two tickets
this game is very exciting to have
tickets to a mandatory work meeting
oh they sent me some uh liquor they sent
me some ginger books
um i don't know if they got my i don't
have the i just have one
for loco in mine not with purple
testosterone
i think these are legal you shouldn't be
doing that well
they got me boom my my baby my favorite
my bullet bourbon and they got me a
black label johnny walker they know how
to treat again
bottles uh you just sent me a loose bag
of vodka
oh i wouldn't drink that oh i got a full
bottle it's not all oh god it is a
piping hot flat diet mountain dew left
in a kia sorrento
mountain dew is the only only piss fba
prove to drink that's dope
did you get any snacks i did uh i was
about to show you my uh
my organic grapes i didn't even know you
could send grapes in the mail
and they and they did smell so great oh
i got snacks i got starburst
oh that's kind of dope
it's just yellow it's just the worst one
oh that sound hey yellow's not terrible
it's just sheepish
i got some skinny pop they sent me a
leaking can of tuna
oh they don't like you dog i feel like
they don't like you
they sent me they sent me a dna kit just
in case they just sent me a bunch of
squirrel dna
and parts for what purpose oh
no
they sent me some air pots hmm
okay uh i'm not getting any oh they did
send me some apple product
oh it's just 11 iphone 4s with
20 20 software so they don't work
oh but but if you you know if you time
travel then you you'll be able
to to talk to everybody in one specific
year
they sent me an emmy for no reason i
don't even deserve this
this is crazy i didn't even package it
up for nothing this seems really mean
they just sent me
a 2020 calendar and planner already
filled out with
nothing hey at least you don't got to
fill it out you know what i mean
yeah kindle so i can read books without
owning them
they sent me some fun packing paper yeah
it matches my pubic hair uh
my box is just lined with actual human
hair
who whose hair is that it says
john travolta ojfx
i don't know oh man well you know how
your hollywood career by the end
oh i spoke to you soon they sent me an
ipad
uh nope it's empty box it just has true
detective season two in it
that explains the blood pocket they just
sent me those shoes that every white
sitcom comedy writer wears
oh man those are going to be great for
the live action version of doug
they said meet jay's baby some fresh ass
jays
oh and there's tickets to the nba bubble
[Music]
they make my dreams come true thank you
hbo max
when's the game oh right now i gotta go
man have fun with your little zooming or
whatever
whatever the [ __ ] this is uh okay well
that was uh chris rhett
living everyone's dream comedy special
coming soon hopefully to hbo max